hey what's going on is filburn it's time
for the thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast Anna
ah just checking in on you I'm just
checking in on you and chicken checking
in on you you know usually I don't have
any guests but every once in a while I
have a special and actually you have
three guests with me we actually
everybody here is on f is for family we
got the the lovely Nia we got Sam
Rockwell and we've got Justin lon
there's no reason to applaud why this is
going to be too positive all right a lot
of myself yeah all right well here we
are everybody well so what brings you
guys out here I heard you two guys do a
little bit of acting work but no do I
tread the board at this one yeah we
actually did meet doing a play no we met
two in a movie we met doing a movie then
we did a play together but we're perma
you're promoting a movie I'm promoting a
movie we elevated our relationship
status from acquaintance to friends over
the course of that play yes we did we
lived in the same with everything warm
it was caught it was a Lanford Wilson
play called the hot L Baltimore yeah you
know whom I am near I know who it was
about a decrepit old hotel and Sam
played the the manager of the hotel and
there all these prophets and different
colorful cares played my part Judd
Hirsch shut Hirsch from taxi
cuz everybody wants to know like you
know when you do you were very good when
you do a play and you got to do the same
thing every single state you get boards
on oh yeah how do you do that in the
standup you got a like mixing yourself
yeah no I get sick of my act yeah I
messed up but I but the thing is every
night I don't have to do the same jokes
I can be like I don't want to do that
joke like you when I saw you in that
play we had your little roped in the
lasso with
the girl with the Schroeder kid with the
rope little cowboy hat was off off
Broadway when the last peep shows out
there non-for-profit yeah he went by the
name buck wild no but like you have to
do that every [ __ ] he was jealous you
were telling me that if you missed when
you you threw it on the bedpost right
yeah used to lasso Nina - yeah and then
she got sick of that I think she was
very patient and then you worked on that
I remember a long time remember yeah it
was about a year I went a few Wranglers
the guy cuz I've done a couple westerns
and they they this guy cliff McLaughlin
taught me he really got me into it yeah
I know I've never known anyone that
knows how to lasso anything yeah I do
now right right you can add that to your
special skills on your resume that's
right when you write in it it's all one
rope it's all it is loose knot yeah
that's something you pull it and then it
comes tight just like your shoelaces
basically yeah it's a tight it's a it's
a it's a much firmer rope than the the
Roy Rogers thing that's a different kind
of thing what was that's a looser rope
like you saw in that movie that Coen
Brothers movie that's like a wrist thing
this is like this is a this is a man
rope but it was also wasn't roasting
right it's a man rope but Ed Harris did
it originally that silly thing that Roy
Rogers did in Alberta Roy Rogers
restaurant [ __ ] but the first time
we did the play Sam Sheppard said I was
terrible and he said I did it for me
said yeah yeah maybe you're a bull rider
oh okay so it's not going well
apparently ed Harris was really good at
it and he did the original play he did
the original and so I had nightmares
about Harris coming to see the show and
he finally did come we thank God I you
know caught everything because the last
Sony and Harrison state of grace is well
amazing good yeah everybody's a bouncy
Riley's great in that everybody's way oh
my god yeah I own wrecked a movie for
people yeah spoilers left
what happens to his character yeah Sean
Penn and Jerry oh yeah I mean that's
like I'm sure bill and I had finished
about playing Westies you know you know
that looks like it's that that's one of
the few books I read more than once oh
yeah
other than kid books to my daughter here
I still have that book you could be a
West you could play a Westie for Seamus
I could play one I could never be one
those guys were [ __ ] lunatics is
there a part of you let's clarify it
could be a Westie I just love in in
Hell's Kitchen now where all of them
grew up is they have there's a bar there
called Mickey Spillane and Mickey
Spillane was I believe the gangster that
ran Hell's Kitchen before the Westies
came along they rubbed him out or
somebody hit him and then they took over
so Mickey Spillane is now a bar there
and what's happened is as that
neighborhood changed over is gay people
moved up it's now becoming gay bar yeah
he would love that I'm sure you would
have loved that the actual image is boy
like on 44th Street or summer 34th
Street around there uh yeah it's in the
40s something like that was I was yeah
do you mind lived over this I was going
down the street and I you know read the
book of zillion times like Mickey
Spillane I know what that is I've been
to Hell's Kitchen I've read all this
stuff above and then I see the big the
big you know multicolored flag down like
that's [ __ ] awesome the gangster flag
come down John Wayne catch your chapter
John Dillinger's yeah yeah like some
manly yeah and now it's just it's great
payback for them yeah testosterone
overload you know that movie was
incredible I remember Gary Oldman blew
me away
but it got buried because I think he
came out like the weekend yeah you're
right or the weekend before after there
were a couple of those like Miller's
cross 19 Goodfellas degrees hot yeah
that Miller's Crossing I don't know
which is the one with John Turturro
that's Miller's Crossing it takes him on
the woods oh yeah that's right yeah that
was like a big like acting thing it was
like one of those like
couple of scenes like like Oh was
everyone doing them in classes and that
sort of thing well it was just one of
those things you remember like one of
those scenes I remember the everybody
was talking about you know have you were
begging for his life
wait I should know this you've worked
with you have you've not worked with the
Coen brothers how's that no no never hey
Cohens if you're listening right Joey
you studied acting I did I did I say
doctor yeah I'm trying to remember it
was so long ago um oh my god why can't I
think I think of in a second but her
name was a Deborah and she did it it was
that bra I'm gonna remember after this
but was it a specific technique it was I
think was Meisner it was that it was
that like a theater in Manhattan and she
had like a big artists retreat in
upstate New York we went to to these
like sort of like farm cabins and didn't
have our phones immerse ourself in the
work and it was amazing yeah she's
actually a really good actress yeah you
were saying that about yeah yes yes
thank you
that's projects you guys have done it
you gotta say f is for family it's
really all the filthy animation that you
guys have ever done you got to admit you
have to have a special place in your
heart I just told my mother dude I was
like where I'm doing a thing with Sam on
bills podcast then and she said 4 f is
for family and she said Sam's on that
and she all of a sudden got really
excited really interested in Efes for
things like oh it's legitimate Sam
Rockwell's on it as I am Laura Dern is
my mother you got to start watching this
I want to have more see I had it I
pitched the thing for the Mike I told
him I said what if what if he gets
taking to like a Scientology kind of
place and then I love that already for
some reason you get kidnapped and or
something happens in Laura and I have to
go in and because I wanted to work with
Laura and then we have to save you you
guys both get captured I don't know
we get round off some of those edges but
I forgot it was it was we develop a
technique to board at the centre of the
earth it was more better what you guys
are doing right now it looks like half
of my pitch meetings all right it starts
off exciting and then just kind of veers
into like isn't it great to register the
when they check out when the executive
when you're pitching and aha and the
smile becomes like all the authenticity
fades away it's hard man yeah that's
hard you can see them kind of drifting
off and think yeah there's a great scene
in Annie Hall where that this got this
this host of the show is pitching ideas
to Woody Allen to write he said you know
I want to come out and do this little
number and Woody Allen's just staring at
him with this smile with this frozen
smile and I don't know how much longer I
can this smile plastered on my face we
watched a bunch of Woody Allen movies
when we met in that door remember we
watched that like Zelig you know oh yeah
at Wayne stuff so you know what you were
talking about kind of sounds a little
bit like the theater the play that we
did of him and we yeah we were looking
for it was right next to us town called
North Adams which come to find out it
used to be I don't know if it still is
and we should probably cut this either
way it was at one point the incest
capital of the world or at the country
yeah you know that who wasn't sure every
town needs an attraction today you gotta
be number one we went through a video
store there to look for Woody Allen's in
your brother it's fine and they're like
Woody Allen and they said well we get
this is a comedy section we went to the
conversation remember that there's a
huge section of deuce Bigalow male
gigolos and they were all taken out they
were all out like that we can't find any
Woody Allen movies there Wow on the
insist that's one of my favorite one of
my favorite scenes is when when deuce is
upside down and he can't get out of that
thing so he swings and
reaches and he grabs the fishtank oh
yeah the whole thing down imma gonna
kill ya it was a great like Rob's I
think Rob Schneider gets like a bad rep
but I think he's always somehow admitted
in hilarious yeah these [ __ ] hilarious
now he makes [ __ ] better um we yeah well
you know would be fun to actually record
with you now that were together and that
would be what are you guys gonna do a
movie again or something people want to
see you guys you're both fun guys you're
both a couple I mean I'm seeing a buddy
movie right here yeah yeah yeah let's
we're doing it that's come up you are
watching the Civil War thing oh how the
Mandalorians with Bader second episode
so baby Yoda
no is it a fresh dick is it a cyborg
better you'll have to check hey hey I
got a question about your stand-up how
do you protect your voice throat cope so
Kofi and then I try to I try to yell
down here well that's smart
blow a couple of guys get that protein
down helps that always shot it Mickey
Spillane
yeah I've definition I've definitely
done damage I used to imitate how my dad
coughs I can't even do it anymore
because my dad would do this cough and
then you know that noise when you're
drawing air in yeah so tough right yeah
yeah and then he do the last one and the
bit used to crush uh-huh and after like
I did it and there's also this is back
when people smoked in clubs and stuff oh
yeah I don't know what happened it just
was not good for the voice and I was
doing a bunch of shows and I did that
bit for like six months and I can't do
it anymore so you really you really
breathe them into the diaphragm because
you were really belting it out there
well I went and I actually believe it or
not I went to learn how to do it because
I still be all up in my throw
my throat was killing me so I actually
went to this guy's house in Boston this
sounds like it's going bad he was uh
like he was I don't know like 8,000
years old and just one of those places
like you walk in and you smell you like
this guy's gonna die soon
there's a [ __ ] grandfather clock and
[ __ ] and he would just go he just gave
me singing lessons it's like I can't
sing he goes he was like it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter you need and I
was embarrassed to [ __ ] and I just kind
of pushed through it and then like this
but there's a weird thing though if I am
up here in the my throat the only way I
can go back down I can't do it
mid-sentence I just have to plow through
that whatever I'm saying up here and
then kind of like but now I really want
to know hydrated in the morning yeah
that's another thing too so cigar things
if I you know I try to limit although I
have in this past month I try to limit
my cigar smoking and if I'm gonna do it
I never do it before a show
yeah that's not true I did it last month
but I try not to go you are I just
smoked like another Oh Sammy you didn't
you didn't baby contraband Wow Ron oh
Nicaraguans I'm gonna [ __ ] throw him
at you I am no they're delicious but if
you can actually get to dessert
these are I just tried these these are
different I haven't just tried those I'm
a dilettante you know what does that
mean you know like a [ __ ] cigar
no way do you smoke cigars oh my dad
does and I love the smell of it you do
shorty shorty fatty Sam how Chris
walking different roads I got you bill I
got you some cigars I thought you liked
them I know you like to smoke
don't and don't inhale
wow these are these for me [ __ ] hell
I got one for everybody where are these
from I got these right up the street
what do we have
unlike good well then then just leave
them with me and I'll stick him in my
humour good bill impression I do it on
the spot I'll take one take one happy
where I feel comfortable doing some
integration yeah but others yeah yeah
yeah I want to tell you something about
cross sorry sorry sorry about that
no this guy told me this whole [ __ ]
story about Fidel Castro with this one I
don't know there's a story behind this
is he he had a long skinny dick and
that's what drove it that's exactly
right
he was a 3-game there's some story about
this particular size a Cohiba that Fidel
that I don't know yes you'll you'll yes
I would know all right any wheel there
you go all right so that we we we did
that that portion of the podcast is do
you you were out talking about Bill and
you know he's protecting his voice yeah
guys do vocal exercises warm-ups anymore
we have lays before movies TV you know
it's funny you should see the might
sometimes in a movie you underestimate
how much screaming you might do you kind
of take it for granted you can but
sometimes yeah I have lost my voice my
movie I have a voice coach tap to do
those with on this is gonna sound
ridiculous on alvin and the chipmunks
cuz I did so much I pitched my voice up
a little bit and it was just a lot on my
they do that for sure tell you but I
everything had to beat there was um dips
and dives that had to be really
modulated yeah and so we did all these
really embarrassing yeah exercise
Dave Chappelle when he used to do the
was a Clinton Bigsby the the the
crackhead yeah he heard his voice doing
that oh no kidding yes he wasn't such a
high register oh yeah yeah it does make
sense I'm just picturing all
construction workers listening to this
who just shot a [ __ ] nail through
there this is really getting a master
class if they're listening to not by me
I'm just having the chitlins Christopher
Walken impressions I'm in first yeah
your audience might be you might be
tuning out at this point yeah they
wouldn't dare don't you dare turn off
this [ __ ] podcast are you kidding me
you're saying you were just analog I'm
Sam Rockwell get it together
[Laughter]
did you hear their podcast about Times
Square yes yeah that's what you guys got
in a fight about the mmm we know I know
I know but but that night we were
watching Wheel of Fortune
which is something we do when they hit
victim
oh my nail fortune always gives out
these [ __ ] awful gifts yeah like back
in the day when you had like the whole
thing would be like alright you got this
whole litany of [ __ ] you can bid on it
was the worst [ __ ] I was like I for $700
I'll take the brass bed frame it was
always a brass bed frame actually
thought it was like like an exotic
they're like a dead skin like a gift
certificate so they always had bad
[ __ ] gifts so the other night
somebody solves some like [ __ ]
impossible puzzle and they possible to
me anyways right and and then the gift
was like a shopping spree shopping spent
sat on the wheel when you pick it up and
they like oh they're getting a shopping
spree excited Dick's Sporting Goods so
I'm like what the [ __ ] Dick's Sporting
Goods and she's me is like what the
[ __ ] you guys how it ever if I was on
the show I just give that to you just
like [ __ ] you
on my own free most addicts leaders
gonna use shopping hence in [ __ ] bass
boats huh and in weaponry I'm not using
any of that oh this is not the Dixon
Hell's Kitchen okay and then all the
Nike [ __ ] is this [ __ ] that they're not
gonna have it their flagship store it's
like the dad [ __ ] try some Nike shirt
whatever their moisture-wicking or so
they keep you cool during the workouts
and he loves them long sleep but usually
mr. moisture-wicking and so I was like
oh well if I wasn't that shopping right
give it all to Bill because he could get
his t-shirts and he was so offended yeah
how [ __ ] cheesy and awful it was you
guys I just give it to you that's like
my god I give it to you so I can see
where would look bad like I'm giving you
the bad but like if they had a gift
surface of Filene's basement right guy
just give it to you it doesn't exist
anymore you know you're old and from
Boston but it was you better gift
certificate to Lechmere I would be like
all right giving it to me Macy's
Woolworths
but movers are you but wouldn't you
would you be offended by that if I got a
shopping spree at Dick's find something
sure exactly yeah I'm a real neelaveni
apologized person um no that's not what
is not within your realm of things that
you would be familiar with Sam I just
don't know I've been there yeah sure
sure
did you have like bias I think I got
someone audition why would you I got
some weights for my dad I got some like
five okay other eight dicks is gonna
love this what can't you get a dicks if
I came home from a game show and I told
my wife there
yeah well I got her something and it was
a shopping spree at Dick's Sporting
Goods
or something that she vaguely
appreciated wouldn't you vaguely
appreciate it dicks there's something
about it said she [ __ ] all she [ __ ] all
over it with me and then she just goes I
just give it to you well let me ask you
when you're if you're eating something
and you don't really like it do you
offer it to her you say ah this isn't as
is not a buyer but maybe you'll like I'm
offended you'd be offended by that okay
I don't like when people do that I don't
know if I like it here try you might
like it I do he descends on everything
that I'm eating anyway I really and then
before she fight she she looks for the
the gooiest most tastiest part of it out
of the [ __ ] sandwich tries to cute
away I'm looking for yeah I know you
study it you get in the middle of the
sandwich where all the good things are
lined up yeah you're looking for every
element not like the pickle slid out so
you missed the pitty on that by the
picture gotta be in there with the
cheese God by the time she does it the
[ __ ] I get it back two sandwiches
like room temperature no where'd you
guys hit me women you went on a date yes
our first I closed the deal yeah oh you
did oh you know the Apollo Theater he
was performing my dad was booking the
comics for the show it was the Sandman I
was it was the summer of 2000 after I
graduate August 2000 oh and he was like
oh yeah I just booked this really funny
wife away from Boston and I was like
okay cool and so we met backstage and he
was very much you know in his space
where he's yeah someone was getting food
I remember when I met you I could hear
somebody get really yeah I want to know
why you were getting booed you know
somebody else yes
I survived somebody else's getting I
don't know who it was but so we did a
quick little high and I remember
thinking like it's not a bad looking guy
and then I just kind of moved on with my
life and then we didn't move we didn't
meet again until years later Oh No
kidding
yeah and then I was like yeah we've been
hacking on that show how'd you meet up
again then at a tough crowd he was a
guest on top crowd with car and you
remembered her from just that one and
you were did you know yeah I didn't
think so I jog did I jog your memory or
didn't you didn't remember me I did
remember you I was like I know him oh
isn't it it's been a long time I don't
know I just never I would I went there
now I started hitting on her and she was
a complete yeah no no just when I was
walking it was when you could hit on a
broad it work you know you can kill two
birds with one stone and still catch the
game now I worked with I worked I don't
feel so bad for guys that can't hit on
chicks where they work I mean what the
[ __ ] yeah Canadian one hours a week
anybody work I don't know that works
there I guess you don't like Paul Newman
and Joanne Woodward with the mini leaped
across the land and that wet cement
outside the [ __ ] Chinese restaurant
up there see okay so this is a fun fact
about Bill I think we've talked about
this on the podcast but it has a very
hard time like he knows what he's trying
to he doesn't know the names of things
so he'll give you only here like content
you will give all these sort of like
weird context clues about what it's up
to you to figure out what are you
talking about we talked about this on
the podcast but you figure it out
so right so you guys are [ __ ]
adorable I just want to say that right
really
you're adorable yeah come on I could say
come on it's okay take it take it in
anyone I usually get what's
anyway so you'll say something like what
did you say well you were trying to say
interview with a vampire but you
then the last days are direct it's the
good the bad in the blood sucking two
good-looking guys you know a [ __ ]
vampire and there's a little girl the
girl I know it's not I know that's not
the name but I'm trying to get it yeah
but you usually the area you read bill I
mean you speak bills language rules yeah
yeah yeah I'm the best goddamn thing
that ever happened [ __ ] job to act
like it isn't it's my honor and
privilege well you're very good at it
thank you we are like 16 years right
yeah sunny days but clouds roll in every
we get along great we do get along but
the thing is is one week when we do do
just like us
vacation and kind of leave like we
immediately start laughing again it's
weird yeah we're really good on trips
the two of us cuz we're like oh we were
actually friends and you actually like
yeah that's great ending time together
yeah it is so low my brother and I
listened and were like oh that's the
that's what you want that's yeah that's
surprise yeah and like you you guys just
went on the trip too you just went to
Europe right I really you know we were
in where did we go laughs Iceland
Iceland how was that oh my god it was
amazing but it was amazing it was
different than what I expected it to be
it was a lot more quaint yeah I thought
I was gonna go and when I do the tundra
what did you do there what kind of stuff
you do we went shopping we went
sightseeing I went shopping we went to
Dick's Sporting Goods they have a great
Dick's there we win Reykjavik no we went
we went whale watching
oh that's cool oh so many well then the
first time I ever fished in my life and
I caught two fish wow it's so excited
I'm soaked that's great that's not
really my thing like me yeah you get on
a kayak or
nah yeah did you bring our daughter came
with us and it was so cute and we have
so many pictures of course she's a
waterfall volcano over a volcano over an
active volcano flew Wow
it was crazy boy that's cool it was
really cool it was definitely one of
those life once-in-a-lifetime
I don't know that I need to go again I
[ __ ] loved it there and I actually
did there was a local comedy club there
and I met you know a bunch of the local
comics where they were all cool there
was this one kid in particular who was
just like he's just silly thrilled tall
kid he was trying lie all these crazy
jokes that would like edgy but really
silly huh and he throw them out there
and he would just wait and see if people
would laugh they wouldn't and he'd start
laughing he's like really really likable
so it must be frustrating then when you
go to these exotic places and you can't
really explore you can't really see much
because it's you have to do a show the
next night well I want that was
different because I went there for like
a week yeah usually when I do a run
through Europe I just I pick a place we
haven't gone to and then we just go over
that get used to the time change and
then yeah we and then we go home and
then he built other fine sorry about
like inviting you out for New Year's he
was doing a gig in New Year's I mean was
the first time you've just been dating
you want to come out and be with me New
Year's I got it broke a guy wears
Livonia Michigan kickers he goes no I'm
in [ __ ] New York City why the [ __ ]
would I go to Livonia it's like I don't
know cuz I'm there like not enough I
like you I need more that's gotta be a
zag I mean like if I heard that of you
I'll that's great I'd fall more in love
that's great yeah until you they're
intelligent Livonia misura
there
countdown something looking back on this
I'm like now I feel bad no but I got you
back for that what do you mean how I
that time when I was doing a gig in the
promoter got me a first-class ticket oh
my god he wanted me to split your buddy
would you do no first class time no he
wouldn't yes yes and I me where was I
Lavanya in coach so he oh you went can't
believe I did that and I was like I'm
the last
how far along were you guys in the
dating process Lauren oh yeah I my whole
career I was in the back of that [ __ ]
plane I just I was at the point where I
yeah I couldn't I couldn't see the
forest through the trees I couldn't see
what a wonderful woman I had I was just
so psyched to finally be there and I
knew that I was gonna go over to Europe
it was gonna be a language barrier
they're gonna be all of this [ __ ]
[ __ ] I was already stressing I needed to
I needed a chair that fitted a human
being needs to shake his head get over
there what I should have done I know I
know I know and since then I've flown
you [ __ ] first-class every [ __ ]
place that's right I don't think I've
ever witnessed bill ashamed there I am
the I am legit ashamed that was a bad
judgment call I did come back and visit
a couple of times yeah it's not that
long I had my cloth napkin tucked into
the front of my shirt that's nice you to
go in coach yeah show support the whole
thing was bad and then also you know the
interracial thing I kind of made her
figure didn't sit in the back of the bus
rosa parks in the air it was ironically
though the seat next to me was it might
have even been the whole row in the
middle was empty so I actually got my
spray they got me pillows and I got to
spread out what so yeah but
but you didn't know a bean like in the
last row or a second to last just people
going the back the worst is being back
things I like to see that Wheel of
Fortune see I got this morning club see
hey you still with the swing for free
yeah yeah and it was super fun
i iced I hate that I did that I'll never
live that there's a lot of this [ __ ]
that I can figure
don't worry that a lot more years left
yeah we'll work it out I'm sure um you
like to ride coach I do I'd like to go
in the specifically in the back because
I heard most accidents most the
fatalities happened toward the front
oh so you're doing this based on just
some dumb irrational you like to ride
coach I know yeah I also don't like
spending I actually like to write code
you don't like to spend money let's keep
going I like to spend money I'm chief I
don't mind it I prefer not to spend the
money on like a fancy first class this
is really I mean I'm really gotten
spoiled I wonder I know you yeah I've
gotten spoiled too I mean I you know if
they fly me out I'll take it no I can't
even think this when I think back like
him when I was 20 years old I took the
greyhound across the country when you
could still smoke on the buses yeah and
[Music]
that was the whole motivation when you
sat in the back was working your way up
to the front my thing now is I also like
smaller airports so I like out flying oh
yeah I love love a love filled Dallas
that's I haven't done that one yet
that's Mother Oakland's really good yeah
in Burbank I just great one here at Long
Beach oh yeah Ontario's not bad they're
just far away but like anything to avoid
that horseshoe of death
lax going in and I like [ __ ] you know
every airline I fly it's they're all
down but by the bottom I was just
waiting I was just I was just looking at
the website of this thing called the
private suite at LAX
and it's like a membership-based thing
and I think for $4,500 a year you can go
like the Prai it's crazy you go the
private way and like you're in your own
little special area with snacks and
refreshments and you realize the genius
okay and it's meant for you to just
avoid like anyone can do up of course
it's forty five hundred what do they
like assure you to your day walk right
to the plane somehow it's all the
wherever its situated you can just walk
later for everybody it's just yeah I
mean you know because when you were a
kid it was so much more glamorous when I
was a little kid I remember you know
people wore ties and stuff to get you
dressed up yeah now it's like a [ __ ]
that's right it's you know and then also
you bus you just kind of walked to the
gate if I remember correctly I got I'm
so old IRA the first time I went that
they just started having metal detectors
because the early 70s they started
having all those hijack you can really
have a gun in yeah they said on this
website they were like it's you know
22,000 steps or something like that it's
probably not that many steps to get from
you know point A to point B typically in
an airport but if you do this private
suite thing you can avoid all of that
and literally your car goes a special
way that's away from all like oh I'd
feel like an [ __ ] I mean the few
times I've had to ride on one of those
little like BP you know get out of our
way like maniacs those carts where they
drive yeah I gotta want to write on a
rascal you know when people are driving
through the airport on one of those
little buggies like that people drive
and I said I want to do that because who
wants to walk all that way and they're
like you can't do that you can't like
why can't you're at a supermarket would
you want old people this age other right
there's people with cart am I taking the
last card I'm sorry I didn't realize
maybe I don't show that I put her in
coach I mean if he's gonna take the
[ __ ] the last seat on the [ __ ] let
me explain something promote this
no no I want to drive the buggy I don't
feel do you listen I'm sorry maybe I
haven't been in a bumper car in a long
time a bumper car yeah I just want to
take the ride you want to take that
buggy right exactly but I don't you know
what I don't have any leg guilt about
that sort of thing I don't feel like I
don't feel like an [ __ ] what
everyone's like here let me take you in
like assure you through the thing yes
thank you very much oh and there beeping
it's beeping at people do what you got
to do to get through the airport I'm
sorry what if some disabled person was
like playing a sweet disabled nun and
they said oh we just used our last card
sorry what oh it's a woman a holy woman
also disabled back they can just drop me
off and go back get her its feedback hit
somebody
no I don't I care about building out
certain certain services and luxuries
that I'm very thankful to have that's
the thing if I wasn't thankful if I
wasn't grateful that'd be one thing but
this is where she makes herself a hero
so it's really okay I sleep very well at
night
I haven't participated in such thing I
support that I think you say yeah which
I was on the gray hand I [ __ ] hate it
well you know plenty of Coach see what
did you ever gonna go back on that this
is this is a story of your life someone
says you you've never going back on that
gray how'd it get here you're like
really what I can't be Christian you
used to go across the country because
your parents were on opposite ends of
the country that's right so I flew when
I was a little tiny kid yeah yeah cuz my
mom was in New York my dad was in
California my mom was Atlanta my dad was
in California so she did the same thing
not the bus but the plane you were a
little kid getting on the plane for the
summers and things yeah flight
attendants were so nice to kid I would
never send my shelves but different
times so you lived in San Francisco
during the year I yeah my stepmother and
my dad and I went to school and San
Francisco and then and the summer I'd
visit my mom and then she was like you
know crazy
oh he Sam's mom is a fascinating woman
she was part of lamagno
she is used like an incredible artist
and part of La MaMa experimental theater
group so Sam grew up around all these
like an anti-government group in the yes
in Harrison Ford was her husband River
Phoenix no no my mother was was in the
nuthouse actually she was in Bellevue
and she had a meltdown and then she did
all these paintings about it and it's a
fascinating crowd of paintings yeah
called the plugs which is a phobia she
is she talked about this but so yeah I
want to see that movie which one just
sounds like a great movie starring
Frances O'Connor speaking of movies you
two big shots box office draws are out
here I know you didn't come out just to
say hello you gotta be you gotta be
promoting something yes yes promoting
what are you promoting I did a movie
with this guy he's an up-and-coming
director named Clint Eastwood you're
saying Clint Eastwood ha Wow
so I flipped with him with an N yes oh
sorry okay and Jon Hamm Paul Hauser
Olivia Wilde is a friend about and and
he did a movie with our friend Mike go
dere he's the lead in nice and white as
many people it's called Richard the
movies called Richard Jewell Richard
when is it out comes out on the 13th
because I do I graduated from high
school that year but I remember that
whole thing oh my god that's just about
down low brothers
Muhammad Ali carrying the torch I don't
remember
John Han well obviously she's a big
Olympian right well and of course if you
grew up in Atlanta that it would be a
different thing
amazing I remember that everything was
crazy oh yeah I'm excited to see him you
probably thought Richard bomber that was
the name that was thrown around so yeah
that's when I was you know terrorist
attacks at the Olympics
yeah 1990 96 with him so was him he was
yeah he was Allstate oh yeah
Paul this actor Paul Walter Hauser plays
Richard Jewell and he's incredible yeah
with funny guy too
I wish I could remember this actor's
name you guys seen the nice guys yet
it's Ryan Gosling and who's the actor
who gets the blue paint on his face ah
he is so goddamn funny he plays his bad
guys oh you're saying like Viggo don't
give me the information he goes we're
gonna cut off your penis
he sounds like laughing they do gonna
cut off his fingers he's [ __ ] I'm
butchering it he's [ __ ] her remember
those performances I remember that movie
with Ben Stiller and where he's in
Iceland or something there was this big
he's in a scene in a belter MIDI right
yeah well turn remember that big big
sort of like Thor yes I love those kind
of performances like what one day yeah
[ __ ] steal the movie you've done yeah
you've done those part that's such an
underrated movie
yeah movie I can't ruin the movie when
he did say he doesn't go nod to like
Abbott and Costello there's stuff in the
bathroom with the the in the stall damn
it that's what comedians can I walk tout
with pistol okay he's funnier than I am
they're crazy
what did God hold back from what do you
know what is you know I think a lot of
that [ __ ] is is there's so many of them
that came from the Mickey Mouse Club
which is almost like old-school
broadville cards came yeah Mickey Mouse
that guy Justin Timberlake right like
they all [ __ ] it hit me baby one more
time
Christina Aguilera but you had to be
funny yeah did to be like a little
showman and I think that that is was
obviously unless they're maybe they're
just really good at picking out talent
deal with it wait
wait clan so you guys said I auditioned
for the Mickey Mouse Club I did no [ __ ]
it was horrible yes dance and sing so I
didn't I wasn't prepared at all this is
put on your saddle shoes Minnie Mouse
voice listen you have to understand that
this was seventh grade okay and I was
having a banner year what your night was
so seventh grade I don't know somebody
do the math 41 do the two that do the
math of whenever so yeah we're born the
same today we have the exact exact same
birthday the exact same June 2nd 1917
how crazy yeah shout out to Jim and I
that's right guys are the same age the
exact the exact number yeah exact same
yeah unbelievable there's seven billion
and there's three 265 days what are the
odds I think it's cool it is cool and we
have like such a friend I was president
of my seventh grade class and I knew
collodion had come to the mall that
better be part of the story
I promise no homework on Fridays I have
no authority yeah they bought it so
anyway I Nickelodeon had come to the
mall I had done all this stuff and I had
won the competition and been on a
Nickelodeon show so I was really like in
the zone okay yeah so when the Mickey
Mouse Club came I was like well
obviously I'm my dishing for that was
not prepared I was not a professional
let me be clear I was not a professional
child at all my mom knew nothing it
wasn't like well what are they gonna
have you do we should look into it let's
find out it was like a lot of excuses to
me it was just like Mia once audition
for the thing I was like yeah of course
of course I can do it of course I can
and they're like okay but we're gonna
have you do some freestyle dance sounds
like okay cool I can handle this I'm
doing my thing you know getting my
little groove on or whatever so they you
know take out the kids that you know
aren't
to par that I'm like thank you so much
so like you gotta say thank you
everybody for coming so I go to the next
one and they're like having a sing and I
somehow forgot about one of the main
things that you have to do on The Mickey
Mouse Club the sing so I was not
prepared I'm not a singer and I had on
the spot a cappella the Sun will come
something
do you remember would you say yeah would
you think the first thing that popped
into my head was eternal flame by the
bed oh yes how does that go
I'm not know do you know the tune you
don't have to sing it I just wanna close
your eyes give me your hand darling so I
didn't go well it didn't and I was cut
from that round and that was it and I
was so sad and my mom took me to Burger
King to make me feel better and that was
it
tell me there's a video of this there is
there literally singing around a bonfire
like an actual flames yeah so I yeah so
that was the end of that I was very
discouraging but otherwise you know it
wasn't for me it's really it's right off
well I auditioned for the The Music Man
thank you know what did you really yep
he's a white he's a white he's a real 76
trombones a big chance for trouble into
civil
all right you're gonna [ __ ] hilarious
story I don't know if I can tell this
story to many people I went to high
school listen to this thing in River
City next stop River City alright so
there was this manchild kid not gray
twice what he was as big as the janitor
like he had the belly of them two ladies
missing was the keys he peeked in like
5th grade I remember the role he got was
when this when the the stagecoach came
to town he was play basically playing
the team of horses and he dragged
everybody yeah and he dragged him in and
I remember he was all amped up he's just
a little excited dragging this thing in
and ever he's like Oh clam he was just
like wait a minute reaming as he came in
wait a minute this is bringing us full
circle this is sad but he's fine now I
think he's like a cop he just had like a
period yeah period in his life where
he's a little awkward he's a little
bigger than us and they made him in
October he was a [ __ ] ox and I just
remember he came into the [ __ ]
cafeteria and he came in the home when
the parents were like oh hey oh it's the
70s alright that's what you did the big
[ __ ] kid who's got that hole he
pulled the [ __ ] is I didn't cast it
don't [ __ ] get mad at me alright I
got to do so you guys hear me read out
loud yeah
right okay everybody let some reason no
cheeto indo-china why baby say it was
founded on the belief that you don't
need to spend a fortune to shop at
Dick's Sporting out you don't need to
spend a fortune on a custom wardrobe
talk about how good men look with when
their suits fit well I'll tell you you
two guys when I see two guys you can
fill out your just lust again I just
want to bite the buttons off your vest
endo Chi is on the ground all right
the world's largest made-to-measure
menswear brand they make suits shirts
coats and more and everything is made
sure what is this product called endo
Chino
indogene Indochina you get to
personalize all the details oh you want
your initials on the inside you want
your face in the lapel you love that
right monogrammed all your stuff is
monogrammed
that's an old-school guy thing that
should come back you have your initials
on your cuff with cufflinks yeah it draw
the lady to it they looked at a
Greenwich Village
who is this GSL guy it's George st.
Louie and he's got a roofie okay you get
to they have hundreds of suit options
for all occasions including work for man
events and even your own wedding the
best part is they are affordable almost
all their custom clothing is under 400
bucks
the process is simple choose your fabric
pick your customizations and submit your
measurements I always think feel like
this coffee's too long and I've never
noticed until three people are staring
at your package delivered straight to
your door you can get your measured
design suit at the nearest endo Chi
notes showroom or do it yourself online
in Indochina it's one of the other can't
start your style upgrade now with $30
off your total purchase of $399 or more
endowed Chino calm when entering BER at
checkout yeah there's a lot less than
wait you want to should read one it oh
my god oh my god I want you to read can
you read one is read one is the
characters from fame yeah
alright I got one for you you want to
you want to read the next one yeah
you read Stan's who should I make sure I
read the website here so that's endo
Chino comm promo code bar for $30 off
your purchases of $399 or more an
incredible deal for your made-to-measure
clothing you really have no excuse
anymore
to wear clothing that doesn't fit all
right now we have Kevin Murphy reading
Stan's stupid dad I wanted to do this
Jill though how many of you know this is
it stands for won't like this I'll do
okay I listen to me yes do that
yeah listen to me right now how many of
you know so much doing that enough is
for families doing a little cole cole
hauser how many of you know someone who
is obsessed with socks did you know you
can you do the guy from the TV guy we
like bragging about how big his dick is
and all which one's that he's the son of
the guy that sikorsky's or whatever
[ __ ] uh on the show and if it's oh
yeah yeah oh yeah that that guy the guy
that's gonna join the army I was too big
I mean I mean you know someone who's
obsessed I forget I there's this Chicago
I don't you know what someone is
obsessed with his acts based on how many
people I know that have a sack obsession
like name people you know that love
sacks I don't know anyone who loves sake
you don't even love sorry I'm gonna
guess almost everyone has at least one
sock addict in their life sock addicts
stance is the brand that made people not
just care about socks but make people
become obsessed with them through the
amazing design and next-level comfort
incredible design and comfort unmatched
durability casual everyday styles like
no shows and crews or performance
athletic products this is long official
on-field sack of MLB you know they are
great South - you gotta know if it's
good for MLB they put them on every
player's feet they're great Sox get to
the website okay they don't make you
read the whole [ __ ] oh really oh okay
you got to do the website here this is
the most important part how do you get
these [ __ ] amazing yeah how do I get
him boom Ali Davidson kid cootie wu-tang
hey honey hey Cudi Cooney though
Carhartt Star Wars Disney x-men you got
a free pair of socks with their next
door to my listeners do all you have to
do is go to the stands calm / / that
stamps.com slash burn now you get Dollar
Shave Club Brando in dry white season
okay wow that was shaved down the shave
club seller shaped anymore in glasses
when I talk about this is a distance I
talked about Dollar Shave Club I can't
stress enough the quality of the
products that's it so I guess that's
human dry white season he's doing a
recycled years developing crafting at
everything they have everything I look
to feel young and smell my honest you
name it they have it I've been a dollar
shave club member for years
I need my loan short first and then I
shave I show Ted Levine I did a movies
in my showed him the Lego the Lego
musical up signs in the lamp oh that's
great he never seen any last is it
really that's a thing
I saw him after I saw Silence of the
Lambs like he was in a movie called
Georgia and he plays like a oh yeah just
like a normal he plays like a
stay-at-home dad like a really light
kind of benign carrot and it was so
creepy because he has these lines that
are like you know I I put Timmy to bed
can you dam which when Sam Rockwell is
acting like he's listening but he isn't
watch this what's more visual that who
you gotta say soon yeah hey yes I really
enjoyed that that work that you did in
that day but you saw the moon before
moon there you saying you gotta see the
Bob
who's [ __ ] awesome yeah yeah yeah I'm
I'm digesting yeah character work you
know that's the thing I feel like actors
like Sam it's it's like he's not even
like trying he's just literally like
absorbing hostile yeah I love this
savant I love it I have one more really
do here thanks all right champagne
shampoodles doodle and met care products
are made especially for poodles doodles
and poos and are also excellent for any
long hair curly and or non-shedding dog
long hair and curly because people have
dogs long and curly heaven this is my
buddy started this my buddy another
business this list of this curly and/or
non-shedding dog long hair and curly
dogs have special hair care needs mainly
Dee Tannen tangling and comb ability
after a bath
shampoodles doodles is a conditioning
and cleansing formulation you're not
gonna forget the name that is pH
balanced for your furry friend and will
leave his or her hair silky soft
manageable fluffy and spelling
delightful where is the website who ever
wanted you to do this made it what's
probably shampoo little doodles okay has
he ever done his Phil Hartman and you
know unites with homeboy was his name
you know Robert Robert Clark want you I
see my Carter I got a car I just want me
to you I did if you like guys good give
it back you know I'd like your car
Scottie let's go inside all right
all right it's like a new year right
making him do that in front of Phil oh
god you'd say Sam and I were so Sam was
he kind of took me under his wing when
we did Galaxy Quest he was like my one
I'd never been to LA it was all so new
to me I saw that shark movie with Phil
and so Sam was the one guy that kind of
like you know I'd hang out with and
stuff and uh yeah and one day Phil
Hoffman who I was obsessed with came to
set like she showed up and said we want
you served the movie with him well Rama
dome first he came there just you were
like my buddies coming you didn't tell
me it was my buddies coming out of this
movie deep deep blue deep blue sea yeah
remember that jokes in it just go oh
you're thinking of no did I say the
wrong what is it
Samuel Jackson has that monologue worthy
gets easy to shark so Tim right there's
the one moment yeah you think he's gonna
have this big like terrowin and then the
[ __ ] shark but Tim Allen came with us
remember right right I don't know if
he'd hang out with you guys a lot but I
don't it was my impression that he
didn't yeah yeah not too much but he was
cool I like came and Phil and so it was
so I was just watching instead of
watching the movie I was basically just
watching Tim Allen and fell off man like
exchange laughs cuz Tim would start
laughing at something cheesy in the
movie and then Phil would laugh at Tim
laughing and they both had these great
big like hearty laughs and I was so fun
it was so fun and then we went out for
drinks at el compadre and that's what I
made you do the impression and Sam and
I'm just like hey I don't want to talk
around Phil you know I'm so nervous
around them and sad 20 years old and Sam
goes um Sam goes oh my god Phil you got
a great impression you there's an
awesome blowing up his spine yeah yeah
you do and so I was too embarrassed to
do it and then we started doing shots so
we started to get real encouraged and I
was like I didn't know where I was just
saying do what I did and people were
laughing except for Phil and Phil goes
that's just me from Boogie Nights it's
not how I sound
is that I've been heat like years later
we like blast about it but yeah alright
that's been the part ok wait can I ask
them about because we talked about
childhood audition stuff like yeah you
guys have oh yeah audition for a play
like when you were like before I do I do
have a good one
I have the one where you brought the gun
the prop gun through the metal detector
before pre 9/11 I it was quick in the
dead and I was practicing that Western
accent word yeah right but then Sharon
Stone decided to give a portion of her
salary to get the Caprio and then I
wasn't know I went to meet Sam Raimi who
you ended up working with him and I was
flown to Arizona I think - or Santa Fe
to do a screen test with Sam Raimi so I
I spray-painted all these big squirt
guns that were originally orange or
green or whatever black and they were
like they look like 44 Magnum right I
had them in my carry-on and they stopped
me you know means now they I was late
for the plane and they stopped me and
then they let me get on the plane they
took the bike took a squirt gun right
how what do you think maybe not I was
you know 24 but my brother Christian
who's a big you know you got a big fan
of both yours we picked up Sam once
after after he had an audition for that
Jesse James movie yes and I'll never
forget seeing you this is one of our
great actors we were seeing him run
across sunset with little toy like a
little toy holster and you had liked
what you had bought like kid like toy
props like it was such a funny sight to
see him cowboy had Jesse James Howard
writes how I met Jeremy Renner who you
ended up yeah
and and he was just he was a while dude
he was but I remember in high school
doing a monologue you would do you would
Sam has this back to the everyone
I watched I watched John Malkovich in
Death of a Salesman I just copied him no
well II turn around and then and then
you dead doing the mod you must have
some really I mean you must have some
really good ones yeah I mean Olivia tell
some good yeah I definitely I used to
listen at the door yeah here did you
ever do that no you hate that I thought
for a second you were supposed to do it
and a few times I started doing it came
back for I always felt bad it can
backfire because if it's going if it's
going bad then you're like hey I got
this and it's going well and you hear
them laughing like will see a Tuesday
haha and you feel like [ __ ] well the
thing is the one time I recall something
like that even remotely happening I was
auditioning for some like independent
man and all the girls were doing it one
way and it because it was getting a
reaction I was like I have to do it the
other way because I'm just not gonna
stand out everyone's doing and I did it
the other way and I ended up getting it
we use hard not to hear when I just
heard them all doing it the same way and
they it was probably yes I was not
actively listening it was passively just
senator can you just say just yeah I
smoked pot but I didn't Hales he's man
you [ __ ] listen it's fine everybody I
caught a kid I got a kid that I used to
see at auditions all the time in the
waiting room god I don't miss those days
I caught him twice doing and I and I
suspect the first one being a phone
getting a phone call and I suspected the
first one of being fake and then when I
heard him do it twice he goes it was
something like this we're all about
dishing for the same part in the waiting
room when he goes he goes oh hey hey
what's up man oh like I did I booked it
ok cool well you know I'm auditioning
for this other thing I don't even know
if I should do it now since that other
thing I just booked seems better do the
same dialogue both similar it was like a
similar like oh I just got a job he's
right like trying to like Sykes
yeah oh my you took it like right
outside I mean like oh yeah so people
could hear I knew a guy that if if any
one of us books something and if you
told him that he always says oh yeah
yeah I was gonna do that but I turned it
down
why I was like I want to keep struggling
yeah I I like I like being in my bed and
seeing my kitchen yeah it's more real
I'll reach my stove did you do as a kid
because I know you've probably doing it
since you were like six I didn't like
doing it when I was at my mom was an
actress and it was kind of the last
thing I wanted to do except all that
[ __ ] eat side of it yeah yeah but
whenever she was part of a workshop a
theatre workshop so if they never needed
a kid we would occasionally you know
beat you with hang yeah if we didn't
comply yeah just enforcing a positive
work ethic yeah it wasn't your favorite
thing no no was the last thing I wanted
to do in fact and then I wanted a
football my real dream was to be on the
gridiron but I did and I was just too
small so I needed a way to you know meet
meet the lady meets it yeah yeah and in
high school that's you know that was the
only thing I could really do yeah it's
kind of followed my brother into her
mm-hm
what about you what what got you into it
um well the first thing I ever remember
doing performance wise was in preschool
and there was like uh I remember Miss
Claire was like we're gonna do Snow
White in the seven drawers and I just
like my hand immediately sharp I was
like I want me Snow White and she kinda
looked kind of glazed over me and was
like ah and just moved on like the white
girl who's not past against time it's no
why no white but this is actually a
white before before I moved to Atlanta I
was living in in Queens New York with
him with my mom my my parents had just
gotten like separated not too long
before so this was the the International
children so it was quite dark yeah and
actually now that I think about it she
may not have been all the way away but
she was very lights good uh-huh
so I was so sad about that and I think
she felt bad so she made me the magic
mirror which is fine but it's kind of
like that ox thing it's like I just said
maybe one thing like you could have made
me you know the mirror does talk to the
Queen about like everything that she's
doing or whatever it is it's like you
could have made me the evil queen could
have given me some kind of like Scary
Spice why would she see ya can't answer
yeah yes well anyway so I yeah that was
um that was what would spice so I really
I had a first course and how this
business works my first moment my first
real play in high school
was um it was into the woods and I
didn't make the final cut to be in the
cast and so there were so many kids who
they had to create like a spillover job
for the all the kids that didn't make it
and so they created that the role of the
woodland nymphs we were woodland nymph
which basically meant we just kind of
lurked around in the background we first
of all we had to wear a unitard which
and I hadn't gone through puberty oh no
I was a late bloomer and so yeah it's
really embarrassing and yeah yeah and
some of the girls they had gone through
puberty know so I was like a little kid
I when I was in high school and we just
had to move scenery around and kind of
lurk that was the worst
yeah why leotard I don't know a unitard
unit I don't know it was like so we
blend in with the back it was like
camouflage we give you a dodge ball a
little bit
[Laughter]
leotard a unitary
that's a good question arts what I could
well you know charge one is that what
that is
nobody means one unisex leotard in a car
right I think I'm leotard it's more some
really it cuts off like on the legs and
a guitar goes all your listeners yeah
this is definitely [ __ ] that has never
been discussing this been so cool level
you go down here you know might usually
like the loaner I don't like have people
in my life and that's nice to you know
not be alone for once well this is like
we just won some contests this is like
we're like a fantasy camp for podcasting
Sam and I both love I don't know I don't
want to speak for you but I we you know
I listen to punk we both listen yeah we
both listen to it and I was listening to
it today because I saw Cuban cigars and
I was like alright better how does he
not like Cuban cigars I better check
that out no but yes I studied stop
smoking cigars no I try you do like you
got the mix no I do if they're real
mortgage if they're real if they're real
the problem is is just most of them are
fake and I used to always hate those
guys you know Mo's was a fake I thought
that they were just being the [ __ ]
[ __ ] on Christmas and it was just
like once you smoke a real one like as
you're lighting it you like oh my god oh
you know right away now what that boxer
on the one podcast that you would
discover and I got hip to him he was NE
faut how was that box there was this
undiscovered it was a boxer had never
heard of John daddy
he was John daddy was a guy when I was a
guy you were going on or on about him I
looked oh no no okay so he was he was a
badass man he was oh oh oh oh oh [ __ ]
from the 1960s and he had the
unfortunate luck of being between Sonny
Liston that's right and Muhammad Ali and
when Sonny Liston when he had gotten to
the point the [ __ ] was his name
Cleveland something Williams yeah this
guy was just like if you look at his
highlights he was unbelievable amazing
and right when he was about ready who
say it's a [ __ ] movie I don't know
why no one's ever developed his
screenplay but like the the guy right is
he was about ready to get his shot Sonny
Liston was starting to go down
and right before Muhammad Ali he got
stopped traffic stop cop [ __ ] shot
him wasn't like a year to wean something
crazy old he never had a great story
what's the cop and came back and it was
super strong too yeah we're going Mike
guy Sonny Liston said I think that was
the hardest the guy the guy who hit him
the hardest was oh is this guy even
Williams movie yeah yeah yeah it's
really quite those are always those are
always the boxing movies are always the
[ __ ] best yeah yeah oh sure
hey do you buy I'm surprised you too Sam
you box a lot I mean I wouldn't call it
boxing I'd call it no hitting hitting
hitting I totally since gym and they all
knew I was there just to get in shape so
used to call me billary Swank show me
some skipping the rope this dude blimp
who worked in big fat black guy I hope
he was fat and they might call it blimp
anyway he looked at me he was watching
me skip rope he goes bill did you have
any black friends growing up yeah I used
to trash me the whole time I always tell
the story though Charlie Murphy rest his
uh when he found out I was going over
things that going over there all right
all right how long you been that was
like I've been there for like a week cuz
I I'm gonna tell you it's gonna happen
about six weeks in he's gonna come up to
you in the day
and then I started laughing then he
laughed I knew that I knew what he was
doing that Charlie Murphy [ __ ] save
he's like he's Allah you must have ran
into Charlie Murphy Tommy asked what it
got in there oh wow oh yeah that well
dual Togo gets mad no go got me Togo got
you in the reflects this and I was I
came over I'm good I'm good acting
exactly alright well that's been the
podcast and Justin India thank you guys
for it's gonna be coming out I don't
know when an early part of next year in
March a okay I don't know Netflix hasn't
told me yet but thank you guys so much
for continuing to do it because people
love the show alright
you